bentornati ragazzi sono youtuber in
italia mi presentano mai fatto video
voglio presentarvi con questo gioco che
a parte le cagate avevo fatto una volta
nel 2000 e zero ed è successo alla roba
incredibile ho visto che hanno
aggiornato o per grotte uno dei giochi
più belli da quando faccio video
probabilmente se sei un uomo di cultura
telo ricorderai sicuramente avrei
comunque a prescindere da ste cagate qua
mi sembra una figata perché hanno messo
la modalità arena dove puoi sfidarti a
caso contro gente incredibile orafo che
il magma arena rock che ives tutto core
tier bandiamo che un quadro ok per non
sono anche ben nomi con i comandi in e
robe però praticamente testa di minchia
c'è gente era un attimo non sei comandi
soggioga un'occhiata nel 1800 fermi gta
murnau aumento
basta ragazzi e speriamo che sapesse non
so come ho fatto non ho e va beh certo
dovete tutti cilardi un attimo perché
non mi ricordo neanche voi mi chiamo
come si fa sta roba
a rimini cono che non c'era un tasto per
salta ok questo per riporre l'arma bene
uno è svenuto va bene
fermati fermati che non mi dicono che
città che aspetta testa rituro non mi
ricordo come te è solo morto non solo un
[ __ ] che aveva fermati fermati un
attimo un attimo non mi ricordo come si
fanno le plancia glielo come si l'acqua
che si lanciano pure gli oggetti ma non
mi ricordo il tasto per lanciare quel
fatto agli aspetti giorno guarda zona
che senta vct fico sta roba
nell'orecchio ne hai uno veramente lungo
a 62
aspetta aspetta aspetta aspetta un
attimo un uso l'ho ucciso sono
fortissimo posso giocare ma solo le
blande mag
[Musica]
e cazzo ho fatto non ho neanche capito
come ho fatto a fare sta roba ma l'ho
fatta viva bene e morto a non è morto la
peccato perché hanno fatto una trovata
una volta faccio una provata allora bim
imi mi dai un secondo giusto per
ricordarmi i tasti per favore ma ecco la
smetta di rame cazzottone te lo scrivo
non lo schivo ok ragazzi ci siamo allora
e adesso che ho capito i tassi dovrebbe
essere tutto abbastanza più semplice
parte far fuori questo che è un fenomeno
come non ci si può fare niente per
tensione poco mi dispiace zio credo che
tu ti sia fatto male ho visto der nato a
nacka ginocchiata in bocca è stato
divertente però chiede weapon dove sta
la web on equa e mia fa lancia
rielaborato che funziona però di lancio
posso lanciarle robert io sto gioco sono
un fenomeno ferro bravo anche una volta
sono anche adesso ma che fallì
sanguinare vabbè ho capito minchia che
botta ma che tecnica e poi è un pure
vinto come fabio papa e mi spiace 6
morte perché a palermo sono troppo fuori
dall'area mia chiamiamo mappa anzi
lancio questo e poi che a mio papà
perfetto magari non lancio meglio che
dite lancia meglio come posso usare
aiuto lo slow motion
ma io non sono motion ho capito quando
si attiva però vabbè che se ne frega
ahia ahia ahia la 6 tappa questo mi fa
comunque allora vicino alla cascata che
chi cade ha perso chi cade ha perso no
vabbè ragazzi allora andiamo sul menu e
andiamo in mag marena proviamo l'altra
che ce ne sono quattro appunto di arene
nuove quindi direi testa le buche sono
bravo e sono potuto essere molto peggio
di me
ma non lo sono abbastanza che è morto
amici occhio che so il sotto l'ici e
morto anche gollum nel signore degli
anelli
ecco fatto non è vero
se tu lanci un'arma l'altro la può
prendere al volo ma cos'è sta roba
ci prova anche se a due armi chiarito ho
vinto io ho vinto io ero con i piedi
incredibile che superi tu fai dove lo
zio lo zio varesotto zio ben e sotto
bike e sotto io ti voglio buttate sotto
non so se riesco eccolo lì luca era
affidato al suo gioco di temi che vuole
tutti i vostri tutti juan angel dove
vieni qua
mannaggia a te guarda gli operati tutti
forti chiare la bella comunque andiamo
nel prossimo consiglio ha visto ci sono
altre due volte al rock game la caverna
della roccia vedi cosa dovrà essere
fatta caverne
non ho idea ma va bè noi siamo sembra un
po una va bene ho vinto io sembra un po
l'arena dei gladiatori però non l'ha
puliscono da un sacco di tempo ma se le
merci is over perché stava continuato a
combattere scusa c'è scritto the match
is over e allora tipico calci vincano
mori ok poterlo fare una roba provata ma
cosa non riuscito a farlo sono riuscito
volevo fare esattamente questo sono
riuscito una volta che mi esce una roba
questo si era fatto tutti quanti poi
sono arrivato ieri ha lanciato l'arma
che non è proprio va bene questo è stato
abbastanza facile e come ultimo ragazzi
abbiamo stucco courtyard che era quella
che giocavo io nel 2013 appunto c'è
ricordi pazzeschi ed è esattamente come
me la ricordavo tra l'altro mamma mia
che faccio lo sta roba
prince of persia aiuto sono vivo a mano
armi ma non fa niente air wing come ho
fatto a fare quel come ho fatto a fare
questa come ho fatto allora signori a
parte questo io vorrei provare un'altra
roba che è questa qua tu puoi andare
anche nel cos'è l'editor non saprete
anche spiegarlo è e puoi caricare degli
oggetti tipo le spine questo mi sono un
po esagerato dogana tutto sto casino
ecco qua o presunto che hanno messo per
taglia porca vacca lo penso qua è mio lo
sfogo nato per me testa di culo da melo
grazie mio nome l'hanno fregato di nuovo
non ce l'ha in mano c'è lemano bene beh
sì ma usano che cacchio fa ma usalo ma
la roma non lo so non l'ho usato è un
marchio di mano per cosa è lo zio vorrei
ti vedo e non è che puoi fare quello che
vuoi
molto bene
aia porca vacca sono morto e me lo
merito comunque ragazzi dal workshop ho
visto che esistono roba tipo i tetti
se tutti puoi scaricare i tetti delle
case e è un parkour in mar ecco punto è
la madonna
c'è veramente hanno fatto una città sud
di hovercraft solo tutta bianca così va
bene ci arrivò ad altro tetto secondo me
ora che figo quando senti che fa lo zio
cioè incredibile sta roba
vabbè tu puoi esercitarti andando da un
tetto all'altro è diventato mirror's
edge ragazzi altro gioco è bellissimo
quanto cacchio grossa stamapa l'hanno
fatta gigante vabbè basta mi sono
trovato boehner un altro raid bove nero
che si chiama arco e frecce vediamo se
riusciamo a fare un qualcosa con l'arco
e le frecce anche sono capito bene cosa
servono qua perché visto poi non c'è
alle armi quindi non ha proprio senso
però proviamoci signore mi scusi aspetta
un attimo che sto capendo come colpiti
l'ho colpito sono forte e non gli ho
parlato una precisa stata nel polmone ma
non gliene frega niente a lui
lui continua imperterrito
seconda freccia nel polmone ma a posto
io tirato l'arco in faccia non è stata
un'ottima scelta l'ha ucciso con la
freccia
gli ho staccato la freccia dal corpo e
lui è morto come possibile non l'ho
colpito con una freccia che ho trovato
bene vediamo se morto sicurezza linee
spara un'altra nelle palle bene
let's go my boys allora dài io direi che
possiamo concludere quale episodi o
perché mi è piaciuto tantissimo anche
perché è un ritorno alle origini o
ritornano origini e io mi divertivo
tantissimo ragazzi o questo gioco non so
se lo ricordate davvero è vedere che a
distanza di tempo ancora divertente ecco
tutto questo non c'è moltissimo da fare
ma quel poco che c'è è divertente non
c'è l'inter a dire vabbè ragazzi come
sensibili è piaciuto al certo momento è
un mi piace schede via canale e lasciate
un commento su cosa ne pensate di horgos
ricordati 20 tempi che uno di leggo
tutti e che sono stati co come vuoi che
noi come sempre ci vediamo l'anno
prossimo vi do bella ragazza
[Musica]